was geht ab ihr sohn max und wir haben
heute eine coole idee für euch und zwar
ins netz
wir werden folgen das mache ihr kennt
vielleicht den neuen snapshot wieder
übrigens wenn ich von wir sprechen das
sind dass just und zwar geht es diesen
neuen snatchers wiederum in sachen
rückwärts langsam sonstwas abspielen
kann wir werden probieren ein paar
sachen mit diesen filtern drauf zu
erraten also wir muten uns gegenseitig
will also wir lieben uns selbst wenn wir
irgendwas sagen nehmen das auf und ja
ich hab mir auch eine elgato und alles
mögliche besorgt dafür dass sich das
aufnehmen kann
dementsprechend wenn es euch gefällt
lastet ein leichter und dann würde ich
sagen muss ich mich mal und fangen
einfach mit dem ersten worte ich starte
ich probiere es jetzt aus als ob es so
gut funktioniert leute alter worte [ __ ]
wie kann das denn sein
ich sehe es an dich und bleib so wie du
bist so wie du bist so wie du bist gut
oder sagt sag mal stuhl und schickt mir
stuhl
ja also rückwärts rückwärts ja hab ich
übrigens ich habe 14
ja es tut mir leid ich vorher aufgeladen
hat ja ok los geht's mit klappt und was
muss dazu sagen ich probiere ich früher
selbst
ich habe das nur so gelesen es kay und
hab dann selber so überlegt wie das
rückwärts stimmt wenn ich es mir immer
an okay aber dann probiere ich noch mal
schauen ob das auch funktioniert wir uns
rückwärts abspielt lager regal haager
regierung agiere angela alle regale voll
okay leute das war egal dass es
schwierig ist ja diese behinderten
geräusche genauso nachzumachen damit was
lustiges rauskommt was mache ich jetzt
gerade fast an jemand anders zu sein
dann wird er denke ich ich liebe dich
gp-triumph ich da mal verkaufen
ich liebe dich ich liebe dich oh das ist
das könnte eher raten also war es ist so
lustig wie das funktioniert laut oder
probiert es aber selbst aus kind das
viel zu cool so ich werde also das heißt
sie anders ist spannend das war diesmal
einsatzfähig entspannt ich also dass du
auch mit einem ganz okay okay ja klar ja
ich dass ich liebe dich ja vor allem was
diese was ich sagen musste war so kurz
oder stuart werden welches von beiden
hast du zwei was jetzt gesagt ich habe
jetzt logo gesagt ich probier irgendwas
richtig schwierig ist jetzt mal aus
sowas ist ein richtig schwieriges wort
okay wenn das funktioniert meine hasler
in der elften klasse die das protein
biosynthese bios trainiert hat aber
bitte was hättest war richtig gut sagt
proteinsynthese rechne aber das hat mir
voll gehört und was sie sagen
vor allem machst du mal irgendwas
richtig schwierig ist und dann sagt mir
was du gesagt hast und ich sage es auch
nochmal überprüfen
leute ich opfere meinen letzten prozente
für euch ich finde das richtig lustig
was können wir noch von scheiß machen
was passiert wenn man diese filter
anwenden
dieser hier schreit real sagen oder so
und ich weiß ja verstanden wobei das
sein was können wir noch mal ich
probiere noch einmal ein richtig
schwerer einsatz
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
ist eine maschine
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen lassen
in den kommentaren wissen wir dass
fandet ich weiß nicht wie viel
videomaterial bei rumgekommen ist wir
sind auf jeden fall fast 18 minuten
gerade und ich habe so viele dateien ich
weiß überhaupt nicht liegt damit klar
kommen werde
aber ich fand es unheimlich lustig jetzt
bin ich gespannt was justin noch sagt
ich finde das richtig richtig cool aber
schade dass man die effekte in die
rückwärts abspielen kann von sap labs
alter das richtig gut geworden wirklich
ehrlich wo pro monat älter und brauchen
auch nena ist stark ja leute dann hoffe
ich euch hat dieses video gefallen
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder check justin ganz oben in der
beschreibung aus und dann bis zum
nächsten mal macht gut tue